alright so let's go through the changes
that I'm making so first of all all of
these cats are going to be in an
unordered list and each one of them will
be a list item now how do I make an li
for every single one of our cats I can
say UL data bind is for each cat list
that'll make an li for each one of the
items inside of catalyst and inside of
the Li I'm going to add a data bind as
well it's going to have text as the name
of the cat if I save this and refresh it
in the browser let's see what happens
and sure enough we get the list of all
of our cats here pretty good now we've
got our cats showing up in a list all we
need to do is make the current cat
change when you click on one of them
that second part is a little bit more
difficult we know that we need a click
somewhere in here we don't necessarily
know what it will be yet but we want a
click on this list item to somehow wire
up to something inside of a pas now like
I said bindings can be a little bit
difficult because it's a little bit more
difficult to visualize where you are
what you're binding context is I might
normally feel inclined to do something
like this on click set tat and then in
our app jas down here in the view model
as it turns out that's not going to work
here's why when you click on this it
looks for set cat within this binding
context which is within the cat itself
what we need to do is get up outside of
that binding context to the view model
the way we get up out of a binding
context is using dollar sign parent I'm
going to save both of these and I'll put
a console dot log statement in here just
to make sure if I go back to my browser
here and I refresh sure enough now when
I click on this I get console dot logs
of high now rather than running console
dot log all I have to do is update the
current cat to access the current cat
i'm going to use self grant cat remember
self is referring to the view model and
that is where
cat lives and what are we going to set
it to well if you look in the
documentation for click you'll find that
when you click on something and it runs
a function it passes in the object you
clicked on specifically the model we're
talking about so when set cat gets run
and the clicked cat model gets passed in
we're going to set the current cat to
the clicked cat to the one we just
clicked on let's save this and hop back
in the browser and see if that works now
if I click on shadow sure enough it
changes and if I click you can see that
shadow has his own counter and Tiger has
his own counter etc so now we've made
the cat's show up in a list we've made
the current cat change when you click on
one of them I hope you've given yourself
a high five although giving yourself a
high five is kind of just a clap so go
find someone else and give them a high
five you just built together with me a
pretty amazing app and a lot of it was
driven by you doing it yourself going
through the documentation learning
things on your own and trying things
seriously good work